gang we got a big announcement a special
announcement kippy and i are related
and we got a special drop in december
21st and boy do i mean special it is all
of our favorite moments from this year's
keep it moving tour plus some behind the
scenes footage it's gonna be fantastic
yes guys it's available on our youtube
page uh so go if you're watching now
subscribe if you listen go subscribe
it's gonna be dropping december 21st
it's gonna be good we need the army of
garbage to rally behind us unite and get
this thing on the moon baby tell
everyone do it
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite new
podcast this is r u garbage it's a
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find that they
grow up to be classy or if they're just
a big old piece of trash i'm your host
stage foley coming at you on a beautiful
day down here at auntie's basement yeah
uh there's bushes missing from the
backyard okay she's selling christmas
trees
to the blind family down the street
billy enforcement she says they won't
know okay so
you can see the neighbors in the
backyard so just be careful when you go
out there i will my co-host is coming at
y'all man from right next to me speaking
of selling christmas trees look at that
shirt give it up for kj everybody hey
everybody thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate view subscribe
on itunes full video available on
youtube and as you know those numbers
are true the roof [ __ ] cooking baby
cooking and then obviously i had i have
to mention the greatest website
contractually i have to mention the
greatest website of all time uh you own
that much
are you www.patreon.com check it out
bonus episodes ayg episodes of hard
feelings live streams the whole [ __ ]
nine yards get involved 18 billion hours
of bonus content over there on patreon
and counting and how about a nice quick
shout out to our producer extraordinaire
the long hair pride of the chicago
comedy scene queen's transplant t-bone
mcscruffins toby mcmullen what's up
dance what up t-bone good to see you pal
i'm doing great i'm eyeing up these
donkeys that our guests brought classic
donkeys you could take the kid out of
new england but you can't i'm a
starbucks man
i'm also a starbucks man the line was
too long
they closed the one around the corner i
don't want to talk about it
gang we could not be more excited to
have our incredibly and i mean
incredibly special guest back with us
again today third time he's going to be
answering your questions you know them
you'll love them co-host of tuesdays
with stories co-host of joe joan
renontalk movies national headliner
kid's a goddamn movie star in the making
watch the [ __ ] out and give it up for
jolt and joe list everybody
where am i where are the cameras
i'll ask a question
i'd build the opposite movie star you're
like where's the cameras
you just hook it
pops right in baby this one here is this
wide
this is
[Laughter]
that's kippy and i and that's
that's the money maker right there
there he is he clams up real quick
[Laughter]
buddy good to see you nice to see you
thank you for coming in do you know this
movie reference you're spilling you're
spilling no
that's the godfather with the little kid
anthony he's got the little thing oh
brando says you're spilling you're
spilling i always wondered what was in
that was there was that water or
pesticide cause he scorched the kid like
right in the face
i think it's water i think he's watering
yeah i don't think he's whacking little
anthony
the scene's reversed the kid falls
through
[Laughter]
he's got the orange in his mouth oh that
that traumatized me seeing that well the
kid got really [ __ ] up that was
genuine oh sure yeah he scared the [ __ ]
out of him
[Laughter]
it's a fine film very good godfather
check it out if you haven't seen it yes
good christmas movie too around the
holidays good point it's always on a a
around the holidays yeah thanksgiving
they used to do the whole the whole show
yeah yeah that's nice um you're doing a
little traveling a lot of trouble going
to germany like right now an hour after
that it doesn't make sense for me to be
here dude
you told me we were scheduling this i'm
like hey we got friday monday tuesday
you're like hey i'm leaving here i'm
leaving for germany on wednesday at
three can you do wednesday at noon i'm
like this guy's [ __ ] wait that's the
next order of business on the schedule
yeah i just got tested luggage is
outside
get packed and head out to germany but
it's uh you still haven't packed no i'm
not i packed quick the laundry is done
so all you gotta do is just transfer it
yeah stack it in yeah count out the
undies the t-shirts the whatever and how
long are you going for just a few days a
few days i did it all i don't know if
this is garbage or if this is the
opposite but i did it to get my delta
status for next year i wanted to really
beef my numbers to make sure i did it i
got diamonds they judge you year to year
right yeah year to year you start fresh
that's [ __ ] crazy so i made it i'm
diamond what's that mean yeah i think
you get to blow the pilot if you want i
don't know i don't even know i've never
imagined the world of diamond i mean you
guys know where i came from you know the
go-kart
i mean mr list you want to take over for
a little while
i got a real cowboy up here
yeah
you're up there doing top gun
he's inverted
um
yeah so i don't know what diamond i
think you get upgraded every flight
maybe a lounge situation maybe you got
to do it yeah yeah you have or do you
have a credit card because that matters
we just we just figured that out we just
got an amex card collectively the three
of us got one i got the card but um
i got your card um
i got the card but it's i don't use it
because i i'm incorporated too so i use
the corporate card and that's different
than what's the corporate card what do
you got so uh it's just a visa corporate
okay whatever but that way when you do
your
stink yeah so you're only going for a
couple of days just the fact you're
going i thought you were getting out of
town for the rest of the year no you
guys are staying there for christmas and
stuff no we're there for a few days
we're going to see these christmas
markets okay i thought when i booked the
ticket the vaccine had come out and it
was spreading around everything was good
and i was like oh by december it's going
to be a free-for-all but now germany is
on fire right yeah i'm going to like the
cooking international dad damn yeah my
wife just got my wife's german she just
got back like omnicron five days yeah
it's it's tearing through there
um it's like a blitzkrieg uh
should i not go no i think you're fine
you're fine i'm boosting i got two
boosters just for fun one in the ass and
one in the face
that just hit me with it i came all this
way
no you should be fine the christmas
markets aren't a good time too they're
outside it's pretty or you wear a mask i
think you got to show a vax to get in
though they should my wife was telling
me you got to get there did you do all
that [ __ ] i'm vaxxed and we get into the
christmas market right you seem
unprepared to be going i'm not that
you're about to get an international
flight in a couple hours well we just
went and got tested and then we looked
it up and they're like you don't need to
be tested to go yeah okay if you're vacs
if you're vac yeah so we just got tested
for no reason i guess there are i was
over there maybe i was over there in
like october it's real loosey-goosey
yeah like no [ __ ] nobody knows why
they're on fire i think
who you flying delta ooh
direct flight no amsterdam
yeah so where are you going frankfurt
hamburg berlin yeah we're going to
berlin berlin only for the things and
we're doing a show too ah there you go
which um yeah which sold out
international
show list there's a lot of uh you guys
probably have a lot of fans in berlin i
bet yeah we don't no i was checking the
numbers
because you were like i'm doing a show
over there i'm like maybe we can do that
there's like seven guys in all of europe
that listen to that that's not bad
hello
good answer
hello kippy um
was that german i don't know
was that latin
you guys rush more fans of course he is
not just so much yesterday another great
line just watched it yesterday why
couldn't you leave well enough alone
fisher was that latin
i love movies um anyways what are we
talking oh yeah germany so we're going
for a few days to see these markets i
don't know i got pages of emails from
fans like you got to see this this and
this i just screenshotted them so i have
to look into it now we have no plan
whatsoever i like it that's good but and
then how do you show back do i just
bring my card because there's no
international passport this is what i
don't get yeah you can show your card
we're i'm going to we're going to france
christmas
and we had was that french i think so
latin
we had to jump through a shitload of
hoops we had to send our vax cards to
uh the french health department get a qr
code all this [ __ ] oh god now he's
panicking i didn't do any of that
i don't think you have to give a
passport joe what's that
um this guy's not making that a
laguardian
i think we'll be all right i think you
you take off
they should check at the airport they
should check your vax card at the
airport and then they might check when
you get there but i don't think they
even checked when i got there well but
now it's different they have all these
new restrict because everyone keeps
sending me don't you think people like
to be a bummer or maybe they're trying
to help
ah
i think they're trying to i think they
definitely get off on i'm
i'm coming from a point of power of
knowing something sure yeah people are
like look at this article people send
send me articles about austria and i'm
like that's a different country
what is a different nation
look at these uh protests it's shutting
down
and i'm like well that's a different
nation yeah it's completely different
yeah i don't even want to think about
that [ __ ] my biggest fear is getting
stuck over there them closing the
american borders and me getting stuck
but yeah that's not good as a u.s
citizen you're always allowed back sure
yeah you might have to take a boat but
you can get here yeah
i don't have to join the french
resistance don't
i think i think we'll be okay if a war
broke out if world war three broke out
while he was in germany and i was in
france are we just that are we are we
enemies then could joe and i gotta go i
think you gotta go underground well
germany's due for a win so it might be
[Laughter]
oh man
all right
we'll cut that silence out
it sounds like somebody said like a
horrible word it just got weird and
we're back
well buddy that's [ __ ] absolutely
fantastic uh we're gonna get to some
cues here as you know when you sign up
for the old patreon uh we'll answer your
questions on the air and we have
international movies
mr joe list here i'm excited all right
here's a travel vibe that's a very
that's a very this is what you're
wearing on the plane right yeah well
i'll put sweatpants on but yeah okay
travel in business what do you find
i think it's regular [ __ ] i don't know i
i was hoping for an upgrade but i don't
think they you have that on those
internationals do you ever ever splurge
for first class
i do domestically but that's what i like
to hear oversea that's a that's a pretty
price
yeah it's a lot also the flight going
over is probably going to be relatively
empty i think so there's not a lot of
people travel not a lot of people can
drive oh there you go i think it'll be
quiet so uh but yeah i i'm dreading it
but you get through it i don't know i'll
take some talent lp i'm put those in my
ass and try to sleep yeah can you sleep
on a plane no you watch a movie
i'll watch a few movies i think yeah i
get something going i just watched
another round did you guys see another
round mads mikkelsen won best foreign
film last year it's amazing yeah i think
you'd love it
i doubt it
i'm a usa man myself
kick rocks it's not like uh hey merkel
get out of here it's not a a think piece
or anything
is there subtitles on that yeah new [ __ ]
my girl tries to put that [ __ ] on
netflix when it's in english i'm like
get rid of that stuff i hate subtitles
we would just talk about it yeah
people watch there's american people
that watch american films with subtitles
on yeah they're idiots it's crazy yeah
it's bananas like extra homework oh it's
the [ __ ] worst i don't like doing it
anyway don't watch it you'll hate it uh
all right let's get into it speaking of
vacation this is from uh aptly named
baby joe uh have you ever gone to the
movies while on vacation
oh yeah really
of course on vacation yeah well
work i don't while it works if you're
away for the weekend i get that but
here's the thing i don't drink so at
night what am i supposed to do
and i don't want to talk to my wife all
day
yeah you go to the movies i love going
to the movies on vacation i don't know
that just seems like that's weird yeah
there's got to be something i mean if
you go to i don't say you go to paris
and it's saturday night you got to be
able to see something we did that
we did that you go to a yeah you go to a
nice french film house
i'll give you all right the cinema
french film house that that's not going
to the amc in paris
watching die hard again
i'm going to like shave film or whatever
seeing independence day
no we saw some french horseshit i don't
know i'll give you that that is that's a
cultural experience yes yeah but on
vacation it's like i'm a day
i'm a day person i go out and do a bunch
of day you hike or whatever you see your
sights your museum but at night
everything's close the only thing to do
is night life [ __ ] and you're not a jedi
i'm not a drinker go to dinner you go to
dinner a nice dinner you go to a nice
dinner we like to do dinner and a movie
have you ever heard of this combo oh
yeah it's not bad you ever go dancing
you guys ever go dancing
we don't go dancing but berlin is a
dance club so maybe we'll dance really i
want to dance to rocket it's got to be
rock and roll music i want to dance to
like [ __ ] bacon over here i don't
want to hear like
you know what i mean you're not on the
rave scene no i want to dance with like
bob seeger
in my socks
that's a real that's a real mosh fit
starter
you know what i mean
everyone goes nuts yeah what about the
beach you do the beach on vacay i like
do you vacay i vacate everywhere i mean
i'm a traveler um
our honeymoon we went to uh i almost
said laguardia not laguardia laguna
beautiful this time of year
we went to terminal d laguna beach
do you know laguna oh it's in california
it's in southern california very
spectacular very nice we went to the
beach every day ten thousand sarah
actually got my wife got annihilated by
a way we kept i kept telling her i'm a
wise guy i'm just picking up on that
yeah so
she's like standing in the breaker she's
one of these people that can't get into
the ocean it's like a lifestyle it's the
same way it's like you gotta get in
there it's brutal like a band-aid right
it's four steps in and like two steps in
four steps back and she's from oh god
i'm a new englander so i'm used to like
50 degree water yeah that's what i am
into shop yes but she's from texas so
it's got to be 88 for her to get in the
water so she's doing this like dainty
horseshit and i always say i'm like you
got to get in because i'm about to get
out yeah like i've been it's been seven
minutes
yeah yeah yeah so she's doing that but
we're in this is in laguna so it's
actually warm but she still is like
afraid so she's standing in the breakers
and i'm like you gotta get this is the
worst pot if you're gonna work past that
yes i'm just like this uh-huh i'm like
i've never felt better my life's like
i'm on heroin out here i love floating
baby just float so i'm like you gotta
get out of there so finally she gets
like in this in between where the
water's leaving and coming in at the
same time that's dangerous didn't you
see north shore it's like a water
yeah it's exact so she we're getting out
and i i'm we're getting out of the water
and i see it coming like i see this
water coming this way and i just high
step run and i look back
and just watch her get
[ __ ] annihilated it was like a
tasmanian devil
and like she just went crazy and i
actually watched she got up and her hair
was just
across no idea where you are it looked
like the ring and then
she was pulling sand out of her [ __ ] for
like six weeks it was just pouring out
it was all in her it was crazy i mean
she was on the ground and she got up and
i had to be like don't move are you okay
she's like yeah yeah and it was like
it's all dizzy i was like you gotta like
she shows her i was like don't move yet
you gotta make sure you're all right it
was
a turn off quite frankly
anyways i don't know how we got there so
i'll go to the beach i like a hike a lot
of hiking vacations
you're outdoorsy man i feel like yeah to
some degree i don't like sleeping
outside that sucks that's insane yeah
that's nice not a camper king camp i
can't but i hate it i'll yeah i hate the
sleepy part yeah i like smoking a cigar
having a cup of tea under the stars
okay that's pretty classy yeah do you
buy cigar are you a cigar guy do you
keep a stock of nice cigars i tried
doing that but i don't know how to use a
humidor i'm an idiot i bought like a 400
humidor and like bobby kelly's like you
put a pack in there i don't know what a
pack is
just keep sodas in there i end up just
buying them i got some hard candy in
there
i'll buy an occasional cigar i'm trying
to cut back
that's great um all right let's see here
this one's from scott has a woman ever
hit you with her purse
no i've never been struck by a woman
yeah and i had this discussion on the
you know what dude podcast and i was in
the minority and i thought i confidently
said to louis gomez i'm like that's
weird that you've been hit by a woman
thinking like it means yeah you're
you're putting yourself in situations
that aren't the greatest i feel well i
was in the minority because every guy on
there was like i think you're gay
something's wrong with you i've never
been hit by i've never even come close
to getting hit by a woman really even in
your i've gotten a drink thrown at me in
my drinking day really yeah
it was like saint patty's day you know
pub crawl
i mean you know tensions that's like 80s
bar [ __ ]
yeah it was someone it was like somebody
had bumped into her and spilled and she
got mad and i you know i didn't respond
so nicely i think you know i think i
totally shut the [ __ ] up and then she
you know responded with a miller light
right to the face like a splash
[ __ ] you yeah like the glass and
everything no like yeah like a splake
held the cup like like a draft she would
smash it over your head no no
you weren't the [ __ ] dudley boys
um but uh yeah it was one of those
things where it was like she got she got
beer spilled on her in a crowded bar on
st patty's day and i'm like all right
i'm sorry and she's like made it a scene
and i'm like we're it's [ __ ] packed
we're in like a mosh pit right now i'm
sorry but it happened i just had this i
was at the um then she i told her shut
up and she threw it in my face ah well
you deserved it but
we were saturday night speaking of
vacations we went to palm springs to go
to travel it's moving nice look yeah
look you almost had me saying laguardia
laguna palm springs germany yeah well
the the laguna and palm springs were
many years apart but we went out there
for the indian wells tennis tournament
i'm a big tennis guy because i'm not
garbage
that's classic kid's classy kip want to
talk to you about ladder love ladder i
think you need a little life insurance a
little term life can't let anything
happen to you no yes on certain times
you got to make a move ladder can help
you got to protect the ones around you
protect your loved ones don't leave me
holding the bag no guys i'm in a
refrigerator box a ladder is 100 digital
no doctors no needles no paperwork when
you apply for 3 million in coverage or
less just need a few minutes and a phone
laptop to apply uh ladder smart
algorithms work in real time so you'll
find out if you're instantly approved uh
if you prefer to talk to a person that's
fine i got a team of licensed agents who
don't work on commissions so they'll
help they'll help you and not upsell you
right no hidden fees canceled any time
the whole nine yards uh finally trying
to get you with the undercoating since
life insurance how are you going to
start the car since life insurance costs
more as you age now is the time to cross
it off your list so go to ladderlife.com
garbage today to see if you're instantly
approved that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
garbage ladderlife.com garbage dewitt
helix mattresses helix mattresses don't
play dumb with me i snooze on one every
night i love healing i know you got the
free mattress what about the big man
over here i'll take the quiz because
that's all you got to do two minute quiz
go on there you take the quiz they know
what you want
sleep uh
hot you sleep gold sleep fat like me
listen i don't got time to be walking
around no mattress store like a bazaar
you ever see the dregs that roll around
in there
they're not ivy league graduates i can
tell you that my friend yeah hey steal
these kick rocks will you yeah a lot of
short ties and short sleeves
go to helix.com take the quiz get
yourself straightened out get a good
night's sleep yeah uh guys i took the
quiz me and my lady they were nice
enough got a 42.
i'm a genius when it comes to mattresses
uh they gave us the twilight model it
was fantastic we had a queen we just
upgraded to a king i don't know i paid
for it i wanna i like i like them so
much i bought this did you use the promo
code did i use the promo what is that
promo code ah let me check why are you
putting me on the spot
it's
healingsleep.com garbage you take the
two minute quiz uh they'll match you
with a customized mattress that'll give
you the best sleep of your life like i
said get your adult mattress they got a
10-year warranty try it for a hundred
nights risk-free they'll pick it up if
you don't love it but i'm telling you
we'll can't beat that helix is offering
up to two hundred dollars off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helix sleep.com garbage
one more time that's helix sleep.com
garbage do it so we're in this
tournament come a long way but we went
out
losing his go-kart we went out there
playing pickleball and there was a lady
and her daughter who was probably like a
teenager and then there was a guy just
by himself and he had a cocktail and a
couple hot dogs and i love anyone doing
something by themselves don't you find
it charming
as i get older i like the confidence of
it i don't always have the confidence to
do it i get it yeah i like a guy he's
like i like tennis no one wants to go so
i'm going to tennis so he had his beer
and his hot dogs and he's like an old
alcoholic so he's trying to like shuffle
into his seat and this much beer spills
on the lady's back and she's like oh
and they get up they move down and they
stare at them and they're like [ __ ]
and they're just like hugging each other
and embracing i'm like you're at a
sporting event you gotta get here
yeah there's a social contract of like
things might not go your way here yes
exactly it's a splash of beer
anyways i got rocked in the face by my
college girlfriend from the back seat
for what
i went to a movie without her because he
made her sit in the backseat
i was sitting in the passenger seat my
buddy was driving she was in the back
seat and just came around
full full punch right in the side of the
face you went to the movies without her
yeah what movie uh i want to say it was
one of the batmans
this girl sounds like a real [ __ ] i'm
telling you she was like pow
[Laughter]
big riddler fan
uh yeah it was i think it was like the
the george clooney we were supposed to
go together
and we talked about it and i ended up
going and just [ __ ] she just rocked
me imagine being upset about missing the
clooney batman shoes which you can also
go see the next day it's not like it was
the only show yeah but that's
i understand where she was coming from i
mean the physical violence was a little
over the top to be honest
you know sucker punching guy give me a
heads up at least yeah shoot me a fair
one will ya
but uh that's big in relationships you
can't go see if you guys if you guys are
if you say oh my god we got to go see
that together and you go see it with
your buddies i see you that's an issue
yeah yeah yeah i said i mean yeah do you
have shows that you guys watch together
no i don't watch shows i'm not a show
guy really i hate shows he'll uppity
this one isn't he no right he's a real
hoity-toity i've tried one
trash joe i can't watch shows but i did
i've never admitted this before this is
this should go on the patreon because
this is some serious bonus stuff here we
go i did go see joker without sarah and
never told her that i'd seen it wow i
respect that because she was big and i
was alone on the road and uh it was an
independent theater single screen type
of thing
and so i got to do it and it's the only
lie i've ever done did you then go watch
it with her and act like you've never
seen it yeah really i liked it enough
that i was like i could see this again
how'd you play that off i just went yeah
i just i will go see it it'll be fun i
just never brought it up or mentioned it
until right now the discussion after the
movie how did that go when you were
talking about the movie this that and
the other thing i liked it better the
first time
no it's like this is my best kept secret
in my life not a secret keeper so this
is this is something but um exclusive
this is an exclusive folks
and animals
you know what you're doing your personal
times your business joe hawk seed
squirrels um we actually have your wife
right here
um but yeah i was just regular i was
like yeah it was good i liked that i was
surprised by this i thought about doing
a couple predictions to really blow her
mind
i'm like i bet he murders this guy and
he lets the little guy go
um
but uh it was good enough that i was
like i'll see this twice wow huh now
she's going to be upset if she should be
upset about that i don't think so
someone will tweet it it's all rats on
twitter the whole family turned out to
be rats
one year she said what she got for me on
christmas on her podcast and a guy
tweeted at me when i got
we're pretty good actually we have a
thing a chicken sandwich don't [ __ ]
say it you know don't there's things
that don't go public here everybody's
pretty good about it oh good yeah well
chicken sandwich
do you guys fight it seem like you guys
don't ever
i can't really see you guys getting mad
at each other not really we're
desperately afraid of confrontation so i
just hold it all the way to heaven
i'm sure she's just trashing me to her
friends but
uh no we don't fight very much we're not
big fighters i'm like i'm a kind of guy
that like if you get in a fight i'd be
like all right that's it we don't have
to date anymore yeah i'm kind of the
same way really yeah if someone like i
see like movies people will tell me
about fights and they're like [ __ ] you
you got a little dick or whatever and
i'm like so you left right that's the
end of it i've been talking to my
girlfriend
that's right out of the script yeah
that's always when i hear you like you
see it in a movie or something it's like
a marriage that's like 12 years and
they've hated each other i'm like just
leave just go yeah i don't understand
that yeah we get along great i think i
can explain that it's um
very low self-esteem okay
fear of being alone oh we do have that
too
so maybe that helps keep you together
you'd walk on a dime she gives you [ __ ]
about the joker you're out
um yeah someone's not gonna get
distracted this is an ayg first we got
secrets we got door knocks
what's happening here let's see who it
is
we're
well i canceled that buddy
yeah
i spoke to uh i cancelled over the phone
who did i scheduled it with you
then yeah because you left me a
voicemail saying thank you for canceling
and letting me know
yeah
wow that was awesome
holy holy [ __ ] yeah insurance inspector
that guy was giving you some [ __ ]
attitude he did he's lucky mr list was
here
yeah he was very upset with me i feel
like
it could have been a lot worse
it's like the cable guy guy from
gabletown trying to ping
um
well that was intent my heart started
yeah i didn't know what was going on our
premium is about to be [ __ ] yeah wow
man i just [ __ ] yeah if anything
if there's any insurance adjusters out
there hit me up they have live monkeys
in the studio
boy i didn't understand any of that that
was so adult yeah well so uh we have to
have an insurance policy here
and uh we've just completed one year
here at the studio and uh
so they have to come and do an
inspection because like we renewed the
policy oh i see and then they wanted to
come into an inspection i said i
couldn't do it and he confirmed for sure
confirmed the cancellation with me i can
play the voicemail back on his side
i guess thanks for canceling giving me
the heads up i don't like to have that
old-ass camera one of those things guys
start snapping pictures he had a camera
he had a little camera if anybody asked
joe's kevin ryan from here on out i
didn't see him that was like get him
anxiety-inducing yeah dude that was uh
wow that was like a sexy side of you
though i i see you in a different light
yeah he's an international businessman
he [ __ ] calls his shots around here i
like the way you handled that too you
were like the buck you said no visitors
yeah
like what the [ __ ] [ __ ] alfred
pennyworth over here
no that was hot i'm like no one can
bother the master now
i feel emasculated that you guys just
really manned up on that guy
i would have been like embarrassing me
on live television
we're broadcasting here like show's over
he said insurance you have to stop
dude that's exactly what i thought i was
like oh we're getting kicked out of here
i was about to get my coat good job
fellas i thought that was like the
german councilman asking for my vaccine
my papers
wow
we've never exact that good german that
was pretty good
i don't think we've ever had anybody
knock here the mailman once i think i
thought it was the amendment i thought
it was going to be your guys's christmas
presents get your credit cards out i did
real good
really really oh
strap in i did really good too i got to
be honest these might be the two best
gifts i've ever bought for anybody but i
digress we supposed to be getting people
your loved ones what are you guys doing
yeah you getting hurt
we're going to i don't know i forget
because here's the thing i actually
wanted to see we're going to houston
we're going to see her family so i got
to buy those tickets
you got to buy them all presents you
know that right no we're doing a secret
santa horse [ __ ] ah i kind of like that
though i like a yankee swap that's where
you get to pick that's
oh that's us yeah our family we make a
thing of it there's yelling i know
people get real mad yeah slurs the whole
thing all goes for the big [ __ ] each
other yeah it's trying to trade up it's
wild there's always like a gang gift in
there too yeah i mean somebody got
somebody a vibrator like a little
[ __ ] steve get stuck with it or
something yeah
do you know what you're getting sarah no
because here's what i that's what i was
going to say i don't want to be one of
these guys who's like oh my pay for ever
but it is tricky
like we're going to germany on my dime
palm springs
i mean we're going on vacation left and
right gloves are awesome and then all of
a sudden i'm like oh [ __ ] i got to buy a
gift but i'm like well can i just get
the credit for
the germany but you guys are married
it's both your money now
you guys have a joint account you still
have separate accounts no joints
he seems like a separate account guy
well i got the corporate i can't be
sharing my does she know what's in your
bank account oh i tell her quite a bit
that's all i have
i'm doing well i don't i got bad teeth
and herpes
i gotta be like you know i got uh
i throw i can throw a couple numbers out
there i've been doing a little face
throwing lately too better believe it oh
yeah yeah
that's all i have for her to be like
but this is my wife had to pay for
everything up until about six months ago
until we started making some cash right
so she i mean she paid for this studio
that we still got to pay her back for by
the way um allegedly allegedly on paper
you know what i mean um so she sent the
insurance guy so nate so now when i pay
for things and i will like make a joke
like ah i got this one i guess she's
like yeah i've been carrying you for
seven years right so i'm like it still
comes back to bite me in the ass you
know i gotta i'll figure something out
i'll get her something damn do you do
like cards are you like sentimental like
that
i'm so good at i write a long thing
really sweet oh yeah they're keepers and
then she tries to do it and you're like
nah nice try now you go somebody do you
go blank inside or do you have a little
thing i get a cute card and then on the
left flap i go it's a sarah and i just
just crammed in there i love you with
all my ways or whatever the hell
[ __ ] oh my god i don't know all my
ways
shakespeare over here
so i'll write something really sweet did
she keep them does she hang for a little
bit i think eventually she throws them
out yeah can i sarah's not as
sentimental as me she's a little colder
i feel like i made a move a film and
then when we finished she was like so we
could throw the script out now right why
and i was like that's the script i'm
like we could probably auction this off
for a couple bucks
but i think she's like clean up
yeah did you dedicate it to anybody the
movie yeah nah it's always cool at the
end that's that should be the christmas
gift right there
you can put it in there if she dies i'll
dedicate it
she's got two weeks left
what's your fridge look like
the front of the fridge magnets magnet
collection tons of them that's where all
our cities are like fun stuff like all
city yeah we collect magnets and
christmas ornaments so
which christmas ornaments is a really
fun thing to collect because every year
you pull them out and you go remember
providence that was fun oh travel okay
yeah but where do you buy them do they
sell them places yeah that's like
year round really yeah this guy's
bonkers
thanks i'm telling you
i don't know if i uh i don't think i've
ever seen a christmas ornament somewhere
in the summer yeah no [ __ ] they got him
i feel like they only pop up in like now
no they got him i'm telling you you
gotta look
i'm i'm coming back with a germany oh it
is christmas time i realized sounds like
a real fun vacation a hike christmas
ornament shopping and a shitty french
couple of rabble rousers over here
i'm a big hike guy you gotta go for a
hike you're gonna you're gonna hike in
germany no go out to like the black
forest or something oh
[Laughter]
what's the record for seinfeld
references in an episode i want to break
it we're
we do pretty well on our own we're very
seinfeld heavy for sure right um
i always love when people when we'll
we'll make them and then somebody just
like on twitter is like i caught that
i'm like yeah that's good it flies under
the radar for a while we had a twitter
account tuesdays with seinfeld and the
guy would go through each and every one
but i think he's dead or something he
probably got tired of doing it it's
pretty ingrained in us like in our dna
that's just how yeah i think that's like
how a lot of people from our generation
specifically in comedy just think yeah
you think in the seinfeld line yeah
there's like seven of us yeah
donnelly mark myself
that's it yeah
i'm like i don't think it's the whole
generation i think it's just a few
autistic people
i know i think a lot of people were like
why are you saying that i meant i don't
think like uh i meant like man it's not
like it was social security
right age of 65.
uh i don't think a younger general i
don't think i meant like our age i don't
think kids in their 20s these kids don't
know
they're all on
that show
to a 20 year old came out before it was
like me watching mash or something i
know i think that all the time that's an
old [ __ ] show i did watch mesh
we've been over this the reason why the
kids today don't know about old shows is
because they don't have to watch them
when we were kids that was all we had
right hogan's heroes what's happening
all that [ __ ] you watched the
[ __ ] the lineup in the summer on fox
29 or whatever it was yeah do you have
cable growing up yeah like to do like
the three basics always cable um
i can't see that i think i remember
getting cable but i was young we had
cable when i was young because we were
big
red sox we needed we needed the cable to
watch the ball game that's all we had
was
converse yeah
we needed those 162 nights yeah
we're still like that in like february
like hey pitchers and catchers are
reporting soon yeah just yeah
let's keep the conversation it's only 84
days not too bad yeah we had cable as
long as i can remember because i
remember watching bruins and red sox
games as really young why did you have
to just out of curiosity why would you
have to watch the red sox on
cable because they were on
like new england sports network well
maybe they were local they had to be on
tv 38 or something yeah
but they had their home games well where
yeah we had i think
i don't know i think new england sports
network nessen if you will
came out when i was a really young kid
pretty sure because i remember we had
upstairs we didn't have cable upstairs
we had one of the tvs with like the
[ __ ] rabbit ears as like that we
would have to have in our room and at
[ __ ]
tv household
we had my parents had a tv so we were
too most of the time we were two
and now we'd go down to my parents
bedroom to watch stuff down to your
parents bedroom well down the hall we'd
say oh
yeah it's one level all right yeah we
got no stairs
first floor master bedroom
[Laughter]
garbage is it a one-level house one
level house no basement no nothing just
a it's a real slab wait you aren't so
it's one it's so real it's one floor one
floor holy yeah i meant down the hallway
it's a small house it's like it looks
like the monopoly house it's a classic
rectangle triangle house there's no
second floor no upstairs no stairs there
was an attic but you had to like grill
the mine to you guys it was a real
ladder and it was like one floor it was
a little square there was no entrance it
wasn't like a polar cord thing sure you
had to play like a crawl space little
team yeah yeah
and only my dad ever went up there
that's a dad's job yeah we weren't
and it was it wasn't like a floor it was
it was a crawl space how many bedrooms
was it or is it is it still that they
still the same house
three bedrooms one bath three bed one
bath that's what you got right three bed
one bath the one bed the one bath is
tough to me we have three bedrooms and
one and a half bath yeah we just have
the one but we have a basement like
normal people yeah no basement what time
i don't like that at all yeah it was
very little my buddy and it's weird that
you guys didn't talk a lot too all being
you know no
no very quiet
it was no good any video games growing
up we were in nintendo i i was on the
main tv or the parents tv
that's i was down down the hallway at my
parents thing you had to play in your
parents yeah because that was like a
smaller apartment
i mean down the hall is like seven bases
honestly
i think it switched back and forth it
would be at one and then the other but i
crapped out on video i got to sega
genesis and after that i was done yeah
same with me i was pretty much out after
genesis yeah i was not a big video game
guy
folks let's take a quick second and talk
to you about the good people at roman
roman keeping it spicy over there hey i
like it hey man we all need a little
help every once in a while in the
boudoir of course in the bedroom your
car battery dies every now and then you
need a jump a hundred percent if the
pipes were broken in the sink you
wouldn't just let water flow everywhere
you'd get it fixed yeah same thing with
the with the piece downstairs yeah you
know what i mean
can't be showing up with a rubber gun
guys you're ready to rock and roll i
know it's roman can help it's way more
ed is way more common than you think 52
percent of guys age 40 to 70 experience
some sort of ed kevin has it i got it
right now
hit that thing with a blowtorch nothing
happens that's why i go to get roman
punch drunk that's why i go to
getroman.com
garbage i speak with a u.s licensed
healthcare professional about erectile
dysfunction and you get 15 off your
first months of treatment um
guys they're not just going to write
pills if it's not uh you know if that's
not that's what's cool about them they
talk to you a little bit they figure out
what works and you know if uh
prescription is is is what's required
they take care of it completely
confidential totally discreet free
online valuation and ongoing care uh go
to getroman.com garbage complete the
online visit take care of your ed
without ever leaving your home one more
time get roman.com garbage if you're
prescribed you get 15 bucks off your
first month of ed treatment make sure
you're ready to have the confidence and
control this season roman ready baby
kj sent you
gang this podcast is brought to you by
the good people at better help doing the
lord's work over there at better health
they really are doing the lord's work
man if you got something that's going on
i'm in therapy right now uh it's a
process it's a big step to take better
help is absolutely fantastic you could
do it in the privacy and the security
and the comfort of your own home it's
not a self-help line all right it's uh
it's a licensed therapist that wants to
help you yeah guys uh and you can be
matched with the therapist in under 48
hours i don't know if you've ever tried
to pin down and find a new therapist
it's not easy it's a pain in the ass it
takes months months it really does to
figure out some of the fits and if
you're in an area where they don't have
certain specialists
yeah better help better health can take
care of you'll get timely thoughtful
responses you can schedule weekly video
or phone sessions you won't ever have to
sit in an uncomfortable waiting room as
with traditional therapy um special
offer for all you garbage sisters you
get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
garbage uh special offer one more time
for all you garbage listeners 10 off
your first month at betterhelp.com
garbage do it do it gangster feel good
back to the show back to the show i do
like an xbox now and again i did played
with my cousins over thanksgiving
they're all kids it's [ __ ] awesome
yeah playing the star wars game it's too
much i feel like an old soul like it's
too many buttons ah yeah the second yeah
the second third like a joystick got
involved i was like all right oh that
that the i don't have the
other joystick yeah the other joysticks
nintendo 64 you could get by with but
the second joystick was bad news i
started with atari one joystick one
button i remember atari that was fun
[ __ ] yeah all right my dad's smoking
planes space invaders
ah the holidays smoking the house you
grew up in a smoking household
you your parents smoke my parents my
grandparents smoked it was in the house
my uncle was a fireman when they went to
give him his physical they're like how
long have you been smoking he's like
i've never smoked a day in my life geez
and they were like oh well your parents
are bad people damn my grandparents
house is one of the ones where you
remove a photo and it's just like yellow
with the little railroad yeah pop up
with the heaters it was bad yeah
what was there an indoor sing ain't too
shabby graham and gramp and then i had
nanny and paw
paw paw paw yeah
i don't know i didn't name them
how about this you want to get out by
the dust bowl you want to hear garbage
my grandparents nicknamed for my
sister's kids grand deb and grand steve
oh my god grand steve crap they just
took their names grand deb grenstein
wait and that's what the grandparents
call the grandkids wait no our grandkids
call them
jesus hey granddad because her name's
deb
there's his granddad and grand steve i
think we invented that that's trash
that's a next that's a level of white
trash i've never heard of them honestly
as they got older together
that's a 40 year old grandfather now
that they've gotten older they've gotten
all this guy's got a leather jacket off
for sure don't call me granddad that's
grand steve all right i'm only 25 for
god's sake
no i'm still looking for some tail all
right one time when he was leaning on
the jukebox
um
they've
used camaro they've evolved into grandma
and grandpa but it was grand deb and
grand steve for a long time which i
liked what'd you call your grandparents
uh great grandmom and pop yeah pop i
think you're [ __ ] on paw and you got
pop hops
all right pop is a dad no
hey pop no my grandfather was popping my
dad's pop now with the kids
i don't know i think pop is a dad better
than grand grandpa or whatever you're
saying
yeah that's a french car i think
um hey grand marshal
when's the parade i'm pops dad i'm sorry
hey pop no no pop's good paws are bad
luck
yeah yeah
it's better than pop no that comes like
a [ __ ] skin hat yeah it's bad put it on
if you're in a shootout in deadwood yeah
paul's okay yeah they got pogba yeah
got shot through the liver what are you
talking about hey paw and i had an aunt
duh it was don pa and they worked
together that's not funny
it's a real trash thing when family
members work together and they work for
the town yeah that's pretty good that's
good benny's though i gotta give you
that that's good man working for the
town is a tough one
that's a tough secretary in road work
[Laughter]
that's what though what's it was a small
town though it wasn't like it worked for
the city no it's like a town yeah my
family's not city material
all are all towns they're no comptroller
i'll tell you that my family i don't
even it sounds like another seinfeld
where's the sneak is in the pool i don't
think my family has set foot in a major
american city in 45 years
my mom's come up to new york once to see
me no the idea like i mentioned new york
they start like grabbing barrels to
throw up and they're like what
my parents had to go into philly
yesterday to go to go to the doctors uh
like that it's getting bad down there
yeah you haven't been there in 20 years
what are you doing getting bad down
there the homeless are on the street
yeah where the [ __ ] do you think they go
[ __ ] bozo
i could never picture my mom and stepdad
like on the subway like taking like the
a train or something and be insane
no insane you forget you know they're
like why would we go to the city that's
insane like as i get older it makes more
sense to me like what am i doing yeah
they don't come to see you at all no
you are
that silence was really sad
well it was a staunch no i was like
every couple of years nope no that my my
wedding they came to
when you guys go there
your mom do you stay at your mom and
dad's when you guys go up there yeah you
stay in the house yeah childhood bedroom
yep same bed
posts are still on the wall no
new bed um it's a guest room now it's
more of a guest room but there's still a
couple things it's a joe-centric
okay because i had this debate with my
sister you guys please weigh in on this
so my sister as soon as she moved out
with her husband
they redid her thing and made it a
family room
i moved out they left my bedroom very
similarly intact okay and she was hurt
she's like as soon as i left you changed
my bedroom
but i think i should be hurt i'm like
they knew you were never coming back
they were like she's taken care of she's
got a husband she ain't coming back my
bedroom they were like yeah let's just
leave it as it is
mine's more hurtful isn't it yeah let's
see if this comedy thing pans out i
would love if they put a jacuzzi in my
room and said he's good he's not coming
back they're still even now like i don't
know we better leave a bed in some books
there dude i don't mean to make fun of
you but how do you turn a bedroom into a
living room this house has bananas is
there a door do you open a door to the
living room it's a family it's a bonus
family it's like a guest room there's a
lamp and a computer in there a couch
it's quite nice
i just i turned my sister's bedroom into
the dining room
i need a blueprint on this house because
i'm upside down i don't know what's
happening it's a nice house it's a
little nice by the way because it's
massachusetts they go for like 400 grand
these houses it's goofy
you're saying not yeah not expensive or
is that expensive i think it's like
ridiculously expensive yeah yeah yeah
like yeah because you're close
relatively close to the city right in
texas for four hundred thousand dollars
you get like a mansion yeah yeah two
floors at least yeah this is a single
floor three bedroom one bathroom for
four hundred thousand dollars yeah
that's all yeah yeah for sure i think
they'll cash it in
no well there's nowhere to go i mean
it's still
they still got a mortgage on it i think
so okay yeah i don't know exactly
you got to get that second living room
yeah
they're not going anywhere
um do you do that thing me and my wife
do it it's very trashy it's like you're
on zillow looking at like 4.7 million
dollar houses i'm being like that's what
they're charging there's only two
swimming pools i'm on zillow constantly
i was doing it last night all i think
about is getting out of here you do
that's that's where's the one place you
would go well i think about um you still
gotta work that's the thing you still
gotta be like i would go back to philly
i would do philly because you can fly
out of philly i dream of a second home
in like western mass like the berkshires
so you could just shoot up there and
have some time in the woods a cigar a
fire a hike those kind of things see a
movie yes exactly
go up there to the movies and come back
there's a matinee playing we can still
make or like living i think of like red
bank like jersey [ __ ] like an hour from
now jersey shore is beautiful you tell
everybody this though and they're like
you're never gonna do comedy again
you're a piece of [ __ ] you can't leave
what about westchester upstate
i don't know i gotta contend with bobby
up there it's a whole thing plus i feel
like bobby would win he's one of those
guys that moves and is like you know
what you got to do is come up here dude
and i don't want to i don't want to let
him win you're in the circle what do you
mean in the circle you would be you
would be in bobby circle yes exactly and
then he's going to tell me all about the
places you got to go to this place don't
go to that place it's too much got you
yeah i would yeah i would like to do
like uh up the hudson somewhere oh
hudson valley forget about it beautiful
nice little cabin up there cold spring
you ever been there buddy that's where i
was walking
main street in cold spring fantastic
fantastic beautiful french restaurant a
nice little bar coffee shop antiques
i'll be in
a nice stretch job with a pool and a bar
[Laughter]
i'm staying in queens baby
yeah i'll probably gonna lock you gotta
get out queens ain't bad i love my
approach i'm the best apartment too i
hate he's not gonna like hate queens
yeah what are you brooklyn no i'm
manhattan oh get out of here i'm all the
way up town though he's in washington
washington oh i remember i lived in
harlem and was like oh manhattan i'm
like yeah 175th
i'm in a cheap seat
uh i got a quick one for you joe so last
time you're on the show you were talking
about you're a pretty picky eater yes
how are you feeling about the food
situation in germany beautiful question
t-bone well they got mcdonald's and
stuff like that are you [ __ ] kidding
me i'm not gonna do a schnitzel i'll eat
some kind of schnitzel-y thing or
whatever but no it's annoying my wife
hates me when i go to play but i'll eat
i do well in foreign countries foreign
countries i'll eat something what'd you
eat when you went to france
uh
a lot of croissants heavy in the
croissants
and um i don't know what do you have
there i mean some kind of chickeny thing
with some jizz on it i don't know i
don't know anything about food whatever
ordinary capital of the world what do
you have a chickeny thing with jizz on
it but they're they're fries in the
pastries i go pastries in france
are you going to paris paris go to
circus
bakery it's right across from the uh
what do you call it movie theater the
notre dame
right across from the foot locker it's
right across from notre dame cathedral
it's called circuit look it up you gotta
look at it's like it's there's no
signage it's just like a lady and her
her dad and they make uh these cinnamon
rolls you'll [ __ ] okay i've never
recommend anything to anybody but circus
bakery all right right by the bookstore
shakespeare i will check it out now for
food when you're walking around are you
just gonna like are you do will you do
research of like you know top 50 places
to eat in berlin are you just gonna walk
by and be like let's just go in here i
got a lot of recommendations from fans
but i'm a big fan of foreign city you
just walk and figure something out yeah
i like this place yeah because if you
have too many plans it becomes a whole
thing there's also no expectations of
like oh this restaurant so go to this
place to go here you just pop in
somewhere and if it's like solid you're
like that was great i had a good time
i'm pushing real hard for that i'm
getting a lot of pushback she wants to
schedule this that and the other thing
she wants to schedule tours
uh like a wine class this that i want to
[ __ ] roll around yeah stroll have you
been to paris no i've never been
anywhere i just got a passport just got
a passport oh wow oh you're gonna love
it paris is like incredible i can either
i can see you loving i ge every time i i
can genuinely because you love stuff
like that you've just been so
anticipated you've been so anti you're
up for so long
for some reason i don't know why
yeah but now i think you're like excited
because i could never afford to go of
course but now now i think you'll love
it uh we've got a beret and a cigarette
holder i'm ready to
roll you're either going to love it or
hey you're going to come back like those
[ __ ] [ __ ] i'm never going to well
i know i'm expecting that i'm going to
keep my mouth shut my my p's and q's get
to hit this circus you're going to love
it you're going to [ __ ] can you eat
stuff are you doing a thing we don't eat
things no over there i'm gonna i'm gonna
enjoy them all right yeah you're
supposed to be doing a thing where you
can't eat things if i'm for being honest
i felt bad i brought the donuts and i
could feel a vibe when i came in with
donuts i could feel everyone be like you
scumbag they're on me a little bit i got
the trainer though i'm going to make
sure i work out while i'm watching how
to eat it should i bring the possibility
should i bring the donuts with me when i
leave
the inspector oh jeez i feel like
they're sitting there open i'm an
[ __ ] it's like a trap oh the atom's
gonna fall on your head
i [ __ ] stuck inside the box i [ __ ]
up i'm sorry it's okay don't be silly
what do you mean but it would have been
worse if i showed up with one donut yes
uh i don't i'm fine with that i mean
everybody's moving and shaking it's new
york city you get a donut hey can i have
a doughnut and drink my tea i think
that's fine you don't show up to a
gathering with a doughnut no this is a
gathering if you would have showed up
with like a bagel with cream sorry i got
to eat this real quick i'm dying yeah
that's one thing you show up with one
donut i got a problem yeah i agree yeah
it's a dick move yeah you're looking at
bozo you said the right thing
well you could have got a boston cream
though a couple of crawlers or something
do it right joe you are from boston i
grabbed two of e i like the glaze so i
grabbed two glazed for me and then two
of whatever
jelly two jellies two jellies i don't
know when you go to your girlfriend's
house for the holi your girlfriend your
wife's house for the holidays i'm sorry
chicken sandwich chicken sandwich
what are you getting her for christmas
um what uh do you take something like a
gift to the family's house like if
you're going over to your brother-in-law
or sister-in-law's house or
mother-in-law's you know what we do and
i think this is the way you should do it
i'm responsible for the gifts for my
family i throw her name on it and vice
versa oh very good that's good right
very good she gets the gifts for her
family you know what they want you know
what's what to spend what's yeah yeah so
i'm like don't worry about that i won't
worry about that but i think he means
like if you're showing up for like
dinner or something like that do you
roll in with something no because we
stay there so i think you just
yeah cause you're going down you're
cause yeah it's not far what if you go
up to bobby's what if bobby and bobby
invite you up for a cookout or something
i'll bring something i rolling in with
something one time not six donuts this
is embarrassing but i did 12 donuts
right bobby bobby had the new house so i
was excited i brought him a home depot
gift card and it didn't go over great i
think it was like strange i think he was
like cars
like everyone brought cannolis and stuff
and spaghetti whatever the [ __ ] and i
was like
here's a box of pasta bobby go nuts
i know you like your carbs but guy
whatever people bring and then i just
handed him a gift card and he was just
kind of like oh how much was on it i
think like 50 bucks or something oh my
god it was the balance from whatever he
returned
884
1832. that's 50 bucks minus a pack of
drywall screws but the rest is for you
big guy go ahead i want to hold on to
that yeah list that's no good yeah a
gift card to a friend is bad it was
strange i think he's just it was very
bizarre
at first i was like he didn't even say
thanks but i think he was just befuddled
yeah i was stupid did you get it to him
with the receipt did you get the gift
card at home depot or did you get that
different walgreens
or whatever
on the way up yeah that's shitty dude
i'm mad at that that's bad
no joe it's orange it just it came
popped off the shelf yeah of that a
whitman sampler and an anniversary card
you might as well just
oh it's goofy i got you some watch
batteries i've had that too sometimes
people give you gifts and you're like
what is what what
yeah i screwed up no good did the right
thing with the donuts how do you feel
about gifts or do you feel you're a good
gift giver oh great gift giver i really
i keep my ears open
around the holidays i really listen i
heard bobby talking about that home
depot car i love well you got a home you
got a new home get around to buy a
shingle you should get them 182
cash cuts
that's nothing to sneeze
oh
that's great good stuff holy [ __ ] all
right let's see
god i'm having a headache here uh having
a headache i'm getting a headache i
apologize um let's see here
this one this is from this is not this
is from drew never had a uh question
read no question just a comment my
cousin got married twice in the same
calendar year and is currently divorced
that's a [ __ ] geez wow look that's
that's moving and shaking right there
i'm not bringing a [ __ ] dime to that
second wedding the same year yeah i
don't think i've ever been to a second
wedding and my dad's
no but you were in one
i forgot i was in my dad's wedding
um no that's
that's no good have you been you ever
been to a second wedding
no
any divorces in your family
oh yeah everybody in my family gets
divorced of my generation i'm the last
man standing still married really wait
your sister like the cousins
yeah sister and cousin yeah the whole
group yeah wow
yeah i know how to pick them up there
huh it's tough you have any affiliation
with her husband at all
we were close i mean like i i'll check
in occasionally yeah it's hard because
you got to figure out what's going on
with the other people yeah it's very
tricky you don't want to overstep it's
tricky because people bring someone into
the family and then you're like all
right i guess this person's part of my
family then they're like their person's
no longer and you're like oh [ __ ] all
right yeah yeah it's weird i'm not the
biggest fan of that i'm like all listen
i can't talk to this guy like you
brought him here i did my job of being
the good brother friends whatever it's
tricky and quite frankly it's uh painful
it's like a weird thing you're like that
was like
friends with this guy yeah yeah you're
like
i don't think i could like i wouldn't be
able to break up with my girlfriend not
that i would want to
chicken sandwich
but like yeah that would like like my
niece and nephew like love her now right
i know her i don't want to do that to
them at [ __ ] 10 years old turn out
like this bozo yeah what like me hey i'm
doing i just yelled at an insurance
inspector i'm doing all right
what was he clown
[Laughter]
um
yeah it's tough divorce is tough
yeah you heard it here first
look
let's do a couple more this is from
geronimo everworn shorts in the snow
yeah but like as a gad that's what i was
doing yeah like i'm the shorts not i
don't i'm not a shorts no like we throw
in shorts we run out yeah
and come back
but no i'm not the guy i always hated
those like football coaches are like i
always wear shorts yeah those people
stink i can do it i've reached you have
to be a certain amount of fat you can do
it i i i'm i'm warm enough in shorts in
the winter that's how fat i am kind of
gotta let the games breathe a little bit
yeah yeah 90 of winter shorts are cargo
shorts four shirts yeah fat guy and
cargo shorts fat guy cargo shorts and
flip-flops in the winter flip-flops yeah
i've seen it
yeah that's christ no no i've put on
like underwear and run out in the snow
you do a snow angel you come back and
you're like
crazy i did it in a hot tub one time you
jump out then like roll around in the
snow and get back yeah yeah are you a
long johns guy oh yeah i just packed him
to go to germany big time thanksgiving
football game had him on yeah you got to
do it john's on vacation man
nothing says [ __ ] like that real sexy
trip yeah it's just 34 degrees we're
high of 34.
we're walking not that cold all we do is
walk low of 25 we're walking everywhere
you put those thermals out it feels good
to take a piss with long johnson oh my
gosh well it's not one piece like the
old west
you're just that's another band it's
another waistband
it's got a flap in the back that's a
real paw move yeah but that was a real
palm it's a fun gag they're not like the
white ones anymore too they're like
black and sleek
or slick
delight when i was a kid those things i
might as well have had [ __ ] a
mattress stuffed in my pants oh they're
if they didn't fit they were terrible
nothing always baggy in the crotch
i gotta fit all your dicks in mine yeah
who was the test model wilt chamberlain
for those things
no she came down to your knees i know
and the fabric i'd be itching all day
sucks nothing hated when your mom was
like do you have your long johns on
you're like
no now they're slick and you have that
fun gag where you take your pants if you
look like a ballerina you dance around
it's very cute
sarah loves it
i think i've told this story before we
were like out playing in the snow as
kids and like i don't know about your
well how was your gear in this in the
winter did you have good
gear where you're like playing in the
snow in jeans we had decent we had
sweatpants but we had uh my uncle worked
on an air force base so he got us these
air force boots which were like
government-issued they were insulated
that's pretty good there was like an
insulation they went up to like the knee
they were badass those were great that's
great but it was a lot of like
sweatpants so you'd be wet yeah i
remember one time i was wearing snow
pants with just uh
long johns on under it and i was
probably like 13. and i went to my
buddy's house
and his parents were like you got to
take your snow pants off if you want to
come inside oh no so i was like no i
don't think i think i'm going to hang
out here in this you know
sled by myself and i did i had to go in
and like sit and eat dinner with his
family in my long johns which is a tough
look for a fat fat 12 year old that's
rough that's like like a cowboy
that's hilarious myself i'm wearing
assless chaps dude it was a bad look cut
out to the outhouse take a dude
did you have you ever speaking of
long johns did you ever have a pair with
the flap in the back
no that seems more of like a your
generation type thing yeah i don't know
how you would [ __ ] in that
that's brutal i would have it all over
me
you feel like i feel like i'm eating the
sun you do now to be honest with you i
don't think i don't think you're a clean
shot
oh no man a lot of control a lot a lot
of road work back there
how oh actually um
how do you we haven't talked about this
in a while and i bumped into you the
other night or like two weeks ago at the
stand and you were you're about to [ __ ]
in public you were about to yeah you're
all nervous he was nervous nelly about
taking a poop at the club can't take a
poop well it's not i hate
i don't mind if it's like uh like the
village underground
at the comedy cellar there's like four
individuals individuals that's what
they're closing that's a home anytime
it's one boot and you know if someone's
waiting they're out there just i should
feel them checking the clock so that's
the problem i don't like a single stall
how do you clean a public restroom if
you walk in at like what do you do are
you doing a wipe are you doing are you
laying down the toilet paper you're just
going [ __ ] ham and if there's piss on
it i'll wipe it i'm not a big germ guy
really i sit right now especially my ass
cheeks i don't have a thing about my ass
kids i don't want to sit and piss or
[ __ ]
but i'll give it a quick wipe i don't
build a for it's just i don't i don't
i don't believe in
how to knock three times to come in i
don't believe in the butt i don't care
about germs of my butt
it's a butt yeah just a nervous aspect
you know people milling around it's the
time yeah it's people outside that's
what makes me crazy because sometimes
you know you have those shits that it's
you're wiping for a half an hour are you
worried about the smell i'm being
worried about the smell if you're like
walk out you're like whoo man no i'm
sorry about all of that that's a skinny
guy thing fat guys that's that petrified
i mean if there's ladies around or
whatever if it's a unisex mate he's
around
[Laughter]
what are your chicks doing later huh i'm
gonna i'm gonna go pinch a loaf i'll be
right back yeah i don't worry too much
about this
take a lap
[Laughter]
anybody got the paper
have you been to the by the way the
creek in the cave in austin is fantastic
fantastic but they have the multi-gender
all-common use bathroom who's [ __ ]
in there i'm trying to think there's
just regular stuff it's like a like
imagine a men's bag with the stalls
where you can see through the crack and
it doesn't go to the floor which by the
way that's one thing that the europeans
have figured out yeah the stalls all the
way to the floor really you can you can
take a huge deuce and no one will know
hurry they're better than us that's very
liberating at the creek though i like
i'd like to go in there and [ __ ] drop
a deuce and just let it all out [ __ ]
showroom would clear out
paint would come off the wall rogan
moves
he leaves town
oh god
yeah but that was nuts i remember like i
would be in there and then like this hot
chick would come in and i would just get
nervous i'm like this is too weird yeah
i don't like that i can't pit i have
more trouble pissing i can't piss with
anybody
yeah i'm a stall guy i'm a nervous nelly
and even any kind of noise it's it's
brutal
noises
[Laughter]
if she's talking about i can't i can't i
need full concentration to piss and to
come also i got a bad brain genital
connection
any kind of yeah
i need i need silence it's embarrassing
i'm a child my uncle i'm like tortured
we used to like try to pee in the water
because we had a boat all day and he
would he knew i couldn't piss with
anything going on and he would do like
circles around me so i'm like getting
like i'm trying to piss in the water oh
you would jump in the water yeah i can't
piss in water either yeah really if i
found a piece of water i have to take my
dick out and piss like i'm in a yard
that's a sex crime so i'll be like crazy
i'll go way deep and kind of just pull
it out
because it's like the the
uh what do you call it
the sensation the mechanics of urinating
yeah i can't do it the waves the whole
thing it's brutal i've swam in the ocean
with like having to piss so bad like an
hour straight and can't do it can't do
it
i'll be on the beach drinking and then
i'll just walk in like waste time i know
i can't well we gotta work on that well
drinking back in the day when i drank
that you lose your inhibition so i would
piss on like a lady's face i didn't care
yeah but now
it's tough it's a hard life i'm living
you gotta next time you go to the beach
you gotta go out there and set yourself
free of that i need well what happens is
like something there's movement
tossed around yeah
so you don't pee in a pool
no oh my god really
i can't pee in a pool doesn't the green
it turns green that's all that's an old
wives town that doesn't happen it's
always got money for those chemicals
i mean come on i'll drink your tendency
i have to pee right now yeah
i'm always worried about it when i'm
peeing in a pain in the ocean because
i've had it happen one time where it was
a brand new bathing suit so like the
fabric wasn't treated yet or something
and the pee kind of
stained it like it disappeared oh yeah
really i walked out of the o and it just
clearly it was like kevin just peed
there's like a discoloration yeah
i worry that it that it attracts uh
predators
because they say that that the warm
water attracts predators
so i'm always scared to pee but i can
all right
now we're judging
no no i i gotta
i gotta get better
i'll make the necessary adjustments
oh god all right let's do one or two
more then get joe's got to get out of
here
what time's your flight uh three o'clock
what no
it's boarding right now
that's it oh yeah i should wrap up soon
but yeah the show's the show the flight
is at 6 30. but it's to jfk so the
traffic can be so we're leaving at like
3 30. nice yeah uber and out yeah yeah
that's the way to do it that's how we
sign off our conversations uber and out
anybody house sitting or anything like
that house-sitting
hey come over i'll check out what's in
the fridge for a little bit uh someone's
got to flex the gaskets
what are the plants i need you to flush
the toilet no no uh no house set anybody
get in the mail or anything i don't
think i just gone for like four days
you're going to germany for four days
it's a quick question
i just wanted the miles go over there go
over there and see a movie and come back
we got the red eye out
it's bad i can't stay for the credits i
do think sarah is put out by it quite
frankly what are you gonna
she doesn't want to go no she's excited
to go i think but i do think it's like
it's a real kick in the vagina like it
talks about your schedule you're all
yeah the travel the time difference but
it is going to be you're going to get
there the the german chris it's a good
time it's always all the holiday always
worth it it's all like you know it's in
like an old cobblestone [ __ ] have you
done it before this this christmas
market no never done it excited it's a
good time to germany i've been to
germany but just like frankfurt for a
day a layover missed the flight kind of
thing okay so
never berlin that airport ain't nothing
to uh shake a stick at that frankfurt
airport oh it's quite a place
all right let's do one morning wrap this
up here um
this is from kefir deli when was the
last time you purchased a 99 cent
arizona product
oh i'm not an arizona guy i've never
done that ever in my life oh man well
because of my acid reflux i drink
exclusively tea and water like hot tea
and water
no soda no
it's weird because i have acid reflux
really really bad but i just
pushed through it yeah
how bad do you have it well i got the
silent wreath so it gets in my throat
right now you can hear that yeah but
it's always burning it sucks take nexium
i take uh just uh pepcid
pepsin yeah day and night
check out next team it's actually really
good okay are you guys putting your
beaks on this or something
plug in big formula over here
um
so yeah i don't drink i don't i never
been a tea guy i feel bad i'm ruining
the last question not at all
i mean what did you drink as a kid yeah
what was in the fridge at the list house
in the in the picture i don't want to
say hey it's gonna be a whole situation
when i tell you what our favorite
beverage is what we're looking for let's
go we're looking for hot tea and water
we were a mountain
a mountain dew family i got an uncle
that still
always has a mountain dew he's like 78
years old just with the mountain dew
jesus that's 20 ounce
i don't know it's like the long thin one
it might be 20. yeah that's one that's a
20.
it's a 20. we love the mountain dew i
like pepsi and coke i liked pepsi coke
mountain dew those are my trucks your
mom didn't make fruit punch or iced tea
in the picture or nothing like that
every once in a while we would
occasionally but not regularly
mountain dew pepsi i had the big two
liter poured into a cup i'd balance it
on the thing like this it would be like
you'd pour it like this off the thing oh
yeah because yeah your little hands were
too yeah i was too little yeah the same
way and then i would open it and go like
a spin like that would go and shoot up
to the ceiling fun move
the evil knee i missed soda i quit soda
a couple years ago i'm big on diet soda
it's not good yeah we love sugar cereal
oh yeah i don't think there was any
restrictions we didn't have a lot of
restrictions i played it fast and loose
no i've root loops
i grew up on mountain dew that's a
family i've never heard like i heard
when you turn a teenager or whatever you
start skateboarding you shouldn't really
be alive right now it was a lot of
mountain dew i had some dental issues a
lot of cavities that that messes up i
think that's a myth no yellow five and
yellow six
i don't know i don't get you dude an
adult drinking a green beverage is
horrific a neon green never it's been a
while i was into my 20s but yeah my
uncle but my uncle has three kids and he
drinks four bottles of mountain dew a
day so
that's why i think it's a myth
i mean he was he's the exception to the
role he was in the delivery room double
christmas my uncle drinks mountain dew
every day he's dropping loads left and
right yeah
no he's i think he's strong
that's great good stuff buddy
thank you so much for coming thanks for
having me yeah what a fun up glad we
made it work absolutely fantastic the
button will be when i missed this flight
to
i'm like [ __ ] we'll do it we'll do a
zoom follow-up call what do you got
coming up you want to focus you know
plug the splash plug plug it all well i
shot this but i don't know when it's
coming out but i shot a special it's in
the cam but now i have no material so i
got to write some material before i can
release it but um i gotta show in berlin
you better get to it buddy yeah i shot a
uh shot a movie coming out especially
coming out both in 2022 but i don't know
when uh joe and ronan talk movies i feel
like if you like the show you might like
that show we talk a lot of movies 100
yeah and so check that out it's on
youtube it's everywhere you get podcasts
run on hirschberg he's a great guy and
uh i got a bunch of dates i don't know
where though i don't know when this
comes out april i'm in boston i know
that patriots day weekend whatever
weekend that is april that's our own
holiday i thought everyone had it
in boston
um
it's april yeah the marathon that's
right oh my god i got a lot of texts my
god
jesus christ um but yeah i don't know my
day i stink at plugging things but check
out joe and ron on talk movies tuesdays
with stories and uh oh i know what to
plug subscribe to my youtube i'm self
releasing this special
youtube followers so please subscribe to
my youtube uh yeah great also subscribe
to our youtube channel because we are
dropping a special december 21st
december 21st baby check it out uh it's
going to be on youtube so go subscribe
now if you listen on the audio go
subscribe so you can watch it we're
going to drop it i believe december 21st
t-bone gets it finished
luke cut that
gang we love you we'll see you next week